keith jennings of dallas texas standing
on the shoulders of other mascot
luminaries like the san diego chicken
the philly fanatic
what can he do on ribbit river
now in frogger the rules are simple each
frogger starts with three lives you fall
in the water you lose a life whoever
completes the crossing with the most
lives intact or gets the furthest moves
on to the next level
straight into jason waterfalls oh my god
that looks so scary it's brutal
terrifying water jets 300 gallons of
water per millisecond will knock you
clean into the water take it take it
down goes frogger keith a quick life
spent wayne's what happened there uh
many things all wrong oh maybe that was
a mascot pratt fall you know they're
always looking for laughing
that splash man that was so good
it's like a tenant over here this is
great right it is like tenant
[Music]
caitlin
this is your first life ready frogger
two here we go yes
she is so tiny
seattle's own caitlyn bear sizing up
what we call jason waterfalls she's got
to get out of the way of those water
cannons fast doesn't have the size to
withstand the battering of the cannons
is going to have to rely on speed and
how nimble she can be you got it you got
it this thing is tough
oh my gosh my heart's in my throat
no see again it's just there's no margin
of error it is like one of those bug
zappers
he's like hold up somebody on there
me where's this waterfall from damon
what's what are its roots chicago
chicago a chicago waterfall you see him
all the time outside of chicago south
side sure yes
big white sox fan this waterfall huge
white sox fan
wow there's plenty more where that came
from check out their second lives
and we're dancing all right keith
be careful oh and he's down i was
literally just about to say this should
be an easy jump for him it's called the
kibosh
great kabocha damon wants junior hey i
like the kaboch
caitlyn barrett seattle washington life
number two he's on the top of that first
stepping stone
and she's off oh down she goes can't
underestimate folks the water cannon's
fatiguing annoying yeah it's watery it's
so watery who will leap to victory and
who will croak on their third and final
life
here comes keith onto tony
will he go shortcut to the lily pad or
go directly to tony's brother tommy
shortcut
oh we're under the lily pad all right
tommy's over there like hey how come
nobody talks to me that's tommy tommy
gonna take this disrespect ain't
nobody's coming over here
italians are not gonna like this no uh
you might have some issues on your hands
uh dear mr damon
i don't like it
stop
keith could have gone to the second
turtle and had the shorter jump but in
taking the shortcut he has bought
himself a showdown with this jump
but it's a big seven foot jump here
those 14 foot logs they're two and a
half feet wide they are way way more
challenging than they look
and he's holding on he's alive he's
alive he's stuck yes sir
that's how you play frogger so now he's
on the loco lilies which go up and down
they go eight feet off the surface of
the water what is this and it's seven
feet between them one of the toughest
stages of the whole crossing well mama
this will end
oh
keith don't bring mama into this
this is gonna hurt like a song gun big
jump coming up right now
here we
go
you